alors nos montebourg est-ce que vous
pensez pas que vous seriez quand même
plus crédible si vous vous occupiez
parallèlement d affaire de la mnef et
pas seulement de chirac mais aussi de
monsieur le guen de monsieur cambadélis
de monsieur dominique strauss kahn je
vais vous dire que le parti socialiste
en est occupé ouais et à empêcher toute
candidature de cela et que par ailleurs
le parti socialiste avait demandé à
l'époque le départ ni à l'ombre de ce
qu'ils étaient mises en difficulté donc
je suis heureux de voir que mon parti
faites un effort dans ce stress penser
que le parti socialiste n'a pas besoin
d'arnaud montebourg mais seulement leur
père qui en a besoin
ça je ne sais pas c'est une question
différente et compliqué eh bien on va
les humains